entre
madame la présidente représentant le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur même le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs je suis
heureux de pouvoir vous présente
aujourd'hui ce projet de loi relatif à
la réponse pénale et à la sécurité
intérieure que défendre mes collègues
eric dupond-moretti gérald darmanin et
marlène schiappa ce projet de loi
s'inscrit dans l'action menée sous
l'impulsion du président de la
république par le gouvernement depuis le
début du quinquennat au service d'une
sécurité protectrice efficace
adapté aux réalités du terrain et
respectueuse de chacun les dispositions
qui composent ce texte d'une première
importance et vise à apporter des
réponses efficaces et adaptés à des
enjeux majeurs que nos concitoyens pour
nos forces de sécurité pour nos
concitoyens car nous devons à nos
concitoyens de pouvoir mieux les
protéger en donnant les moyens
techniques et juridiques aux forces de
sécurité d'agir contre les rodéos
urbains par exemple nous devons en même
temps nous donner les moyens de protéger
les femmes et les hommes qui au
quotidien sur le terrain oeuvre pour
notre sécurité
permettez moi tout d'abord de revenir
sur les dispositions qui sont portées
par le garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice
le 14 avril 2021 la cour de cassation
confirmait la déclaration
d'irresponsabilité pénale du meurtrier
de madame sarah halimi attal
reconnaissant que l'auteur avait agi
sous le coup de l'abolition de son
discernement
tout en consacrant le caractère
antisémite de ce meurtre cette décision
qui a provoqué un profond et très
légitime sentiment d'incompréhension a
pourtant respecté l'état actuel de notre
droit même lorsqu'un mise en cause a
provoqué la perte de son discernement il
ne peut répondre devant la justice des
actes qu'il a alors commis cette
impossibilité de distinguer l'origine de
la perte de discernement n'est plus
acceptable tel a été le sens du pot des
propos du président de la république en
avril dernier les choses ont été dites
clairement notre droit positif doit
permettre de la distinction entre un
individu atteint d'une pathologie
psychiatrique qui le prix de tout libre
arbitre et celui qui doit sa folie à la
consommation volontaire
de produits psychotropes c'est pourtant
un principe en six endroits nul ne doit
pouvoir se prévaloir de ses propres
turpitudes
notre responsabilité collective et donc
de corriger la loi lorsqu'elle doit
l'être mais il est impératif et je me
dois de le rappeler de respecter toutes
les précautions notamment
constitutionnel qui requiert la délicate
évolution du régime de la responsabilité
pénale les dispositions votées à
l'assemblée nationale respecte cette
ligne rouge infranchissable
que gouvernement et députés en tracé et
ne jamais les franchir on ne juge pas
les fous
c'est un principe indissociable de notre
état de droit et donc de notre
démocratie c'est pourquoi elles
introduisent une unique dérogation au
régime de l'irresponsabilité pénale
lorsque la police y l'abolition du
discernement et provoqué par
l'intoxication
volontaire d'un individu qui cherchent à
se procurer le courage dont il craint de
manquer se donner les moyens d'un
passage à la parfaitement assumé ne
devra plus permettre à son auteur de
faire l'objet d'une déclaration
d'irresponsabilité pénale et d'échapper
ainsi à sa propre responsabilité
votre commission a en revanche souhaité
remplacer l'article 1er du premier du
projet de loi par une disposition
complétant le code de procédure pénale
pour imposer au juge d'instruction de
renvoyer devant la juridiction de
jugement une personne dont l'abolition
de discernement résulte je cite au moins
partiellement de son fait
comme l'avaient déjà indiqué devant vous
le garde des sceaux lorsque cette
disposition avait été débattue le 19 mai
dernier dans le cadre de la proposition
de loi de madame goulet sur
l'irresponsabilité pénale le
gouvernement ne peut et ne peut pas en
l'état y être favorables si le juge
d'instruction estime en pratique à la
suite de plusieurs expertises
convergentes j'insiste sur ce mot
convergentes qu'il ya eu violation
abolition totale du discernement
pourquoi l'obligé à renvoyer le dossier
devant la juridiction de jugement sinon
pour inciter cette juridiction à prendre
le contre-pied de l'avis unanime des
experts pourquoi donc exigé un renvoi
qui s'appliquerait de façon très large
puisque la rédaction retenue retient que
l'abolition du discernement pourrait
simplement résulté au moins
partiellement de son fait je peux évoqué
à titre d'exemple cas d'un malade
schizophrène qui oublieraient de prendre
son traitement et commettrait un oeuf
l'occasion d'une bouffée d'idées
délirantes le risque de renvoyer les
fous devant les cours d'assises est
alors majeure et nécessite que l'on
s'interroge très fortement sur sa
constitutionnalité
c'est aux juges et aux jets seul que
doit revenir la décision de renvoyer
devant la juridiction de fond pour
décider de la responsabilité pénale ce
n'est pas à la loi de le lui imposer
ainsi nous proposerons de rétablir le
texte de l'article premier dans sa
version adoptée par l'assemblée
nationale de revenir sur les
dispositions de votre commission de
matic l'arctique afin de créer une
exception précise et limitée au principe
d'irresponsabilité pénale en cas
d'abolition du discernement
lorsque celle ci résulte d'une
consommation de psychotropes ayant pour
but de se donner entre guillemets le
courage ou plutôt la lâcheté de passer à
l'acte ce projet doit propose également
la création de deux nouvelles
infractions inédite dans notre droit
pénal afin de combler le vide juridique
dans les situations similaires à celles
révélées par la très douloureuse affaire
halimi votre commission a accepté le
principe de ces infractions et le
gouvernement s'en réjouit en cas
d'atteinte à la vie ou à l'intégrité de
la personne ces infractions viendront
sanctionner d'une peine d'emprisonnement
lourdes la consommation vous le violon
terre de psychotropes lorsqu'elle a
provoqué la baule assez de l'abolition
temporaire du discernement sous l'
empire duquel l'auteur a commis le crime
ou le délit spécifiquement prévus par
ces pour ces nouvelles incriminations
condition indispensable à la
constitutionnalité de ces nouvelles
infractions comme vous l'a rappelé le
conseil d'état l'a mis le mis en cause
en absorbant ces substances le quantum
des peines sanctionnant ces infractions
sera fixée au regard de la gravité des
atteintes causés à autrui portant les
peines encourues de 2 à 10 ans
d'emprisonnement
les débats parlementaires ont déjà
étendu la liste des infractions aux
cadets viol d'actes de torture et de
barbarie barbarie et d'incendié
volontaire ayant entraîné la mort qui
n'était initialement pas couverts par
ces nouvelles infractions autonome que
votre commission n'a pas souhaité
conserver pour autant il semble
nécessaire de maintenir cette infraction
afin par exemple de réprimer l'individu
qui sans livre volontairement au point
de déclencher sous le coup d'une crise
de delirium tremens eu un incendie
provoquant la mort de plusieurs victimes
ce projet loi comporte par ailleurs des
avancées procédurales souhaité par les
acteurs judiciaires lorsqu'ils sont
confrontés des délinquants refusant
toute identification l'effectivité de la
loi pénale nécessite d'établir
efficacement une identité judiciaire
nous avions la responsabilité de
renforcer le cadre procédural de cette
identification
désormais les enquêteurs pourront
recourir à la prise d'empreintes sous
contrainte dans le cadre d'un dispositif
équilibré intégrant des garanties
renforcées à l'égard des mineurs il
s'agit d'une disposition pragmatique
destiné à lutter contre l' usage de
multiples alias qui rendent les merengue
mis en cause insaisissable se déclarant
tantôt mineurs tantôt majeur au gré des
interpellations
une autre avancée adopté en première
lecture à l'assemblée nationale est
attendu par les professionnels
désormais la juridiction improprement
saisie sur le fond mme ans de l'âge de
l'auteur pourra placer en détention le
majeur où le mineur afin de le présenter
devant la juridiction compétente dans
des délais très courts la procédure
pénale actuelle présentait une lacune
car elle permettait de remettre en
liberté des prévenus suite à la
déclaration d'incompétence de la
juridiction ce ne sera désormais plus le
cas cette disposition est essentielle
afin de garantir l'effectivité de la loi
pénale nous devons aux victimes bien sûr
nous devons hausser au vrai le mineur
qui pourront ainsi bénéficier des
dispositifs éducatifs adaptés à leur âge
nous assurons ainsi une réponse pénale
proportionnée permettant à tous les
acteurs judiciaires enquêteurs
magistrats avocats éducateurs de
retrouver le sens de leur mission
respective je me félicite que votre
commission après une expertise attentive
et conserver d'économie générale de ces
dispositions je souhaite revenir
désormais sur les dispositions
présentées par le ministre de
l'intérieur il s'agit des articles 5 à
11 et 17 et 18 du projet de loi qui vise
à rendre l'action des forces de sécurité
de l'état plus efficace tout en se
dotant d'outils permettant de réduire
les risques encourus par les policiers
et gendarmes dans le cadre de leurs
opérations
l'idée d'abord de mieux protéger les
forces de l'ordre contre le délit de
refus d'obtempérer et lutter
efficacement contre les rodéos en
matière de délits routiers et
comportements dangereux sur nos routes
je suis heureux de constater
[Musique]